[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de présidentielle 360 voici les
titres exercice démocratique obligé le
grand débat des 11 candidats a-t-il
vraiment été utile très attendu par les
prétendants à l'Élysée absent de la
première confrontation il a permis de
faire émerger des personnalités sans
forcément modifier les intentions de
vote des électeurs on en parle dans un
instant justice demander le programme on
continue de passer au crible les
propositions des candidats et on
s'intéresse ce soir au moyens de la
justice et à la politique carcérale
alors que le Sénat formule 127
préconisations pour redresser une
justice qui va mal suite de notre série
consacrée à la campagne vue du terrain
on ira dans le quartier du neof à
Strasbourg ou des association ont lancé
un challenge citoyen pour faire baisser
le taux d'abstention dans les banlieu
reportage dans cette éd iition et je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à
cette édition en direct sur Twitter
hashtagprésidentiel 360 pour
m'accompagné cet après-midi tamtran Nui
en direct du Sénat et Nora Amadi et
Cécile Sixou à Strasbourg le multiplex
c'est tout de
suite mais avant de développer tous ces
titres scènes d'horreur en Syrie avec
une attaque chimique responsable de la
mort de moins 72 personnes dont 20
enfants le régime de Bachar ADM toute
responsabilité un projet de résolution
présenté à l'ONU cet après-midi a été
jugé inacceptable par Moscou jérôe
rabdi nouvelle tension internationale
autour de la question syrienne le
bombardement au gaz toxique d'une ville
du nord-ouest de la Syrie tenue par les
rebelles soulève du pape au secrétaire
général de l'ONU des condamnations quasi
unanimes François Hollande souhaite une
forte réaction après cette attaque la
plus meurtrière depuis 2013 en Syrie il
doit y avoir des sans qui seront prises
par rapport au régime syrien parce que
depuis longtemps on dénonce ce régime et
ceux qui ont des complaisances avec ce
régime aujourd'hui doivent également
rendre des comptes une réunion d'urgence
a été convoquée à l'ONU mais la Russie a
d'ors et déjà prévenu qu'elle ne
validerait pas une résolution condamnant
le régime de Bachar alAssad soutien
indéfectible du pouvoir en place à Damas
la Russie explique la présence de
produits chimiques par un entrepôt qui
aurait été touché par les bomb
dans l'enceinte de cet entrepôt se
trouvaient des ateliers de fabrication
de mines artisanales rempli de
substances toxiques des combattants
rebelles livraient des armes chimiques
en Irak depuis cet
arsenal pas question donc pour Moscou de
lâcher son allié nouvelle illustration
des divisions entre les Occidentaux et
la Russie sur ce tragique dossier et on
en vient à présent à l'analyse et au
décryptage du grand débat qui a réuni
hier pour la première fois 11 candidats
à la présid C sur un plateau de
télévision on vient d'ailleurs
d'apprendre et bien que France 2 renonce
à organiser un second débat ce sera donc
le seul de cette campagne présidentielle
avec la totalité des candidats pour en
parler Michel Sames m'a rejoint bonsoir
Michel avant de voir avec vous
finalement qui est le grand gagnant mais
aussi quels sont les perdants de ce
débat retour sur les temps forts de cet
exercice avec Fabrice
cunet mes chers compatriotes mes chers
compatriotes mes chers compatriotes
française français il faut retrouver les
jours heureux ensemble nous irons
beaucoup plus loin mais alors comment
rassembler les Français il y a des
batailles sociales à mener on a besoin
d'une transformation profonde moi je
m'adresse au travailleurs et voilà en
résumé mon plan qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un président exemplaire c'est d'abord
un président qui dit la vérité au
français sur la réalité de la France et
la réalité du monde un président
exemplaire c'est un président qui met en
œuvre les engagements qu'il a pris
devant le peuple quel que soit les
difficultés un président exemplaire
c'est un président qui respecte son
premier ministre et qui respecte le
gouvernement et qui respecte l'équilibre
des pouvoirs prévus par la Constitution
et le pire c'est qu'en plus le FN qui se
dit antiystème ne s'emmerde pas du tout
se protège grâce aux lois du système
grâce à l'immunité parlementaire et donc
refuse d'aller aux convocations
policières donc peénard donc là tout ça
ça illustre la ça illustre ouais quand
nous on est convoqué par la police nous
vous voyez par exemple on a pas
d'immunité ouvrière désolé on y va ce
que vous proposez c'est la guerre
économique et nous ne sommes ni la
Suisse ni la Corée du Sud Madame Le Pen
la réalité de notre vie économique c'est
que ce seront des destructions d'emploi
ce que vous proposez c'est le
nationalisme moi je viens d'une région
ou les conflits entre justement les pays
d'Europe qui et Jean Lassal l'a très
bien rappelé il faut savoir d'où on
vient et où cette séparation nous
ramènera le nationalisme c'est la guerre
puisque vous proposez d'être demain chef
de l'État et bien respectez ceux qui
vont mettre en œuvre les politiques pour
lesquelles peut-être vous
serez
person j'aime la f c'est pour ça que
jeux la vous voulez la ruine de notre
pays j'aime la fonction publique voilà
pour les moins forts de ce débat Michel
c'était un passage obligé mais est-ce
que ça a vraiment été utile c'est vrai
que la question s'est posée est-ce que
c'est démocratique oui c'était
totalement démocratique est-ce que
c'était historique oui encore une fois
11 sur un plateau totalement historique
utile il y a que les Français qui vont
pouvoir en juger est-ce que ça a fait
bouger les lignes peut-être moi j'ai
envie de dire peut-être et oui est-ce
que les Français en savent plus est-ce
qu'ils ont été éclairé très franchement
17 minutes par candidat on a pas
beaucoup fait de fond on a fait plus de
forme et des phrases assez bien cislées
comme on a entendu entre benau Amon et
François Fillon à l'instant mais bon
vous avez eu en tout cas un aperçu de la
situation vous avez eu un aperçu
physique c'est très important parce qu'à
partir de maintenant vous allez pouvoir
comparer comparer les styles qui sont
très personnels donc pour certains le
temps de se faire une opinion est très
important chez les indécis peut-être eux
aussi ont eu le temps de faire leur
opinion quen retenez-vous Michel sur le
plan politique notamment moi ce qui m'a
frappé hier soir c'est que parmi les
candidats 9 sur 11 sont en tout cas
contre l'Europe ou voi en l'Europe le
mal français euh ils veulent soit sortir
soit renégocier les traités ils ont fait
cette élection finalement une sorte de
référendum contre l'Europe ça c'est le
petit he petit de sur un plan plus
tactique politicien positionnement je
vais filer un peu la métaphore
tennistique si vous me le permettez on a
eu certains candidats qui se positionnit
un peu sur le jeu de fond court qui
était un peu en position d'attente
c'était même assez surprenant de leur
part vous aviez aussi les adeptes de la
montée les attaquants et ça ceux on les
attendait c'était les petits candidats
ils avaient besoin de se montrer de
jouer l'attaque et à ce petit jeu il y a
deux gagnants Philippe Poutou très
clairement l'un des deux candidats
d'extrême gauche qui est un peu le
porte-parole de de ceux qui ont un
travail normal comme il comme il aime se
nommer combattu il a défendu lui aussi
les intérêts des ouvriers on lui doit la
première grosse attaque de la soirée on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure il n'a pas eu
de pudeur de gazelle comme avait dit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y est allé
franchement sur les attaques il s'est
pris Marine Le Pen d'un côt côté
François Fillon de l'autre et il a
attaqué nous convoqué par la police pas
d'immunité ouvrière cette petite phrase
a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux lui
nous dit que c'était pas préparé on va
tendance à le croire si vous vouliz
marquer les esprits hier soir il fallait
donc attaquer c'était le mot d'ordre
l'autre gagnant c'est Nicolas du
poignant qui pareil s'en est pris à
François Fillon il est allé chercher
François Fillon car tactiquement il a
besoin des voies de la droite des déçus
de François Fillon et déçu des affaires
bien évidemment et visiblement ça a
fonctionné parce que dans les sondages
il engrange les points en ce moment
alors ça c'était pour les petit un
candidat entre guillemets bien sûr qu'en
est-il pour les grands ceux qui avaient
le plus à perdre notamment Michel alors
il y avait ceux qui avaient à perdre et
ceux qui avaient espéré encore gagn en
légitimité peut-être même à rassurer
c'était le cas de Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui
il a été jugé le plus convainquant par
un sondage il a même réussi l'exploit de
passer euh près de Philippe Poutou
Natalie to presque comme un centriste
donc il l'avait dit au début il était là
je suis prêt pour gouverner il fallait
donc rassurer pour les autres c'est
plutôt mitigé François fillan attaqué
sur son bilan attaqué sur sur les
affaires il a essayé l'anaphore du
président exemplaire ça a pas soulevé
les passions Marine Le Pen a été plus
sur le créneau n'était plus du tout sur
ce créneau de la candidate du peuple
contre le reste du monde il y en avait
d'autres à côté d'elle ceux notamment
qui sont contre l'Europe du coup elle
était totalement sur la défensive moire
peut-être même un petit peu agressive
benoî Hamont lui il a changé
d'adversaire exite Emmanuel Macron il
s'en est pris à François Fillon à Marine
Le Pen peut-être sous la pression d'une
partie du Parti socialiste du coup
c'était plus très clair pour pour le jeu
de Benoît amamont il a plus on a cette
France désirable dont on a beaucoup
entendu parler hier soir c'était
totalement absent quant au favoris des
sondages Emmanuel Macron aucune prise de
risque d'accord avec presque tout le
monde c'est même François lino qui lui a
dit Monsieur
monsieur Macron vous êtes d'accord avec
tout le monde rire de l'assistance voilà
on a eu ces petites phrases ces petits
moments de gloire pour les uns pour les
autres ce quart d'heure de Andy warel
comme ilael ce quart d'heure de
célébrité pour les uns et pour les
autres historique je le disais au début
de T interven tion pourquoi parce que
France 2 a donc annulé et donc cette
première à 11 candidats sera donc la
dernière merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse Michel et on reviendra
d'ailleurs sur ce débat avec mes invités
dans un autre débat à 19h c'est une
nouvelle affaire embarrassante pour le
Front national selon le Canard Enchaîné
le parquet de lî a ouvert une enquête
préliminaire portant sur des soupçons
d'emploi fictif au sein du groupe FN au
conseil régional du nordpatcalis
explication de Fabien
REER l'enquête a été ouverte en janvier
2016 sur la base d'une lettre anonyme
c'est le groupe Front National au
conseil régional du nordp decalais entre
2010 et 2015 qui est en cause Marine Le
Pen alors président du groupe FN à la
région aurait utilisé des financements
régionaux au profit du parti et de la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 les
enquêteurs s'interroge sur le nombre de
collaborateurs parlementaires employés
par les 18 élus frontistes à la région
35 en 5 ans contre seulement 12 pour le
groupe PS pourant majoritaire ou h chez
les républicains également visé par
l'enquête David rachelin salarié comme
assistant de groupe dans le nordp
decalais pendant 3 mois en 2010 alors
qu'il est conseiller municipal à Fréjus
puis siège au conseil régional en PACA
la même année les principaux intéressés
dénoncent une manœuvre politique c'est
étonnant de voir que 15 jours avant la
présidentielle on s'occupe d'un dossier
d'il y a 7 ans ça vous paraît pas
étrange vous on aurait souhaité mettre
sur écoute le directeur de campagne de
la première opposante au système on s'y
serait pas pris autrement vous êtes sur
écoute je suis certain je pense qu'entre
le 1er et le 2è tour marine va être
accusé par le parquet financier d'avoir
volé la Tour Effel au terme de l'enquête
préliminaire le parquet de Lille
décidera ou non d'engager des poursuites
le Front National est déjà visé par une
enquête pour des faits similaires avec
ses assistant parlementair européens et
on va prendre à présent la direction du
Parlement européen à Strasbourg on
retrouve notre journaliste spécialiste
des questions européenne norura Amad
bonsoir Nora les députés européens
viennent d'adopter une position très
ferme pour les négociation du brexit
qu'en est-il
exactement effectivement dalphine une
position très ferme 56 voix pour 133
contre et 50 abstentions c'est par une
écrasante majorité que le Parlement
européen a adopté une résolution fixant
les principes et les lignes rouges des
du Parlement européen donc sur la
question du brexit première priorité les
droits des citoyens européens ceux qui
vivent en Grande-Bretagne il serait près
de 3 millions et ceux qui vivent dans
les 7 pays membres de l'Union d'autre
part le coût du divorce ce coût il est
astronomique hein pour les Britanniques
il s'élèverait à 55 milliards d'euros un
coût que réfutent les Britanniques
aujourd'hui et donc qui fera l'objet
d'une négociation ce coût donc du
divorce fera l'objet donc d'une
négociation entre Michel Barnier et le
ministre chargé du brexit et ce sera
certainement donc l'une des premières
phases de négociation enfin aucun
compromis ne sera possible pas d'Europe
à la carte pour les Anglais c'est une
position qui a voulu extrêmement ferme
le Parlement européen aucun accès au
marché intérieur s'il n'accepte pas les
libertés inhérantes à ce marché la
liberté de circulation pour les biens
les services les personnes et les
capitaux et le Parlement là-dessus est
donc sur la même ligne que les États et
la commission aucun compromis non plus
sur les négociations à venir il faudra
d'abord régler ce divorce avant de se
mettre en ordre de bataille pour les
relations futures entre la
Grande-Bretagne et l'Union européenne et
pas non plus de possibilités de
négociation bilatéral entre certains
pays européens et la Grande-Bretagne
quoi qu'il en soit le délai des 2 ans
est fixé à terme ce sera donc ici au
Parlement européen de voter sur le futur
de ces négociations et sur le texte qui
en sortira merci beaucoup Nora pour ses
explications on en vient à présent à
l'actualité du Sénat avec la
présentation d'un rapport sur la
psychiatrie des mineurs le parent pauvre
de la médecine en France pour en parler
on va tout de suite retrouver th tranu
avec le sénateur RD d ce Michel Amiel
rapporteur de cette mission
d'information
oui je suis avec Michel Amiel qui est
donc rapporteur de la mission
d'information sur la situation de la
psychiatrie des mineurs en France alors
Michel Amiel il y a eu plusieurs
rapports sur la question de la
psychiatrie en France mais pas sur celle
des mineurs qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous avez choisi d'axer votre réflexion
sur ce sujet alors tout d'abord un état
des lieux un état des lieu un constat
hélas difficile la pédopsychiatrie est
véritablement sinistrée c'est vrai que
l'état de la psychiatrie en général
n'est pas terrible la psychiatrie a
toujours été un petit peu le le parent
pauvre de la médecine et je dirais la
pédopsychiatrie encore bien d'avantage
ma formation de médecin étant très
imprégnée de ces questions-l il a sans
doute été pour beaucoup dans la
proposition de faire une mission
d'information sur ce sujet au titre de
mon groupe RDSE et donc tout est parti
mi-novembre et nous avons travaillé je
dirais à marche forcée compte tenu du
calendrier actuel cour courts de façon a
bouclé cette mission avec un maximum
d'auditions et de déplacements sur le
terrain et finalement 52 propositions
trois objectifs principaux lesquels
sont-ils alors si on part du début la
formation nous manquons de
pédopsychiatres parce que nous manquons
aussi de de formateurs de de praticiens
universitaires donc ça fait partie de
d'une part importante des propositions
deuxièmement la prise en charge depuis
euh la détection depuis le le le
signalement depuis la prévention et la
prise en charge de façon la plus précoce
possible et ensuite accès euh des
recherches dans le sens de
l'épidémiologie dans le sens des
neurosciences dans le sens aussi de la
recherche clinique que ce soit pour les
médecins que ce soit aussi pour les
profession paramédical comme les
infirmiers et les infirmières et nous
proposons dans le cadre de la réforme
LMD de de créer un Master 2 de
spécialités en psychiatrie pour les
infirmiers infirmières puisque comme
vous vous savez cela fait des années
maintenant que le le diplôme d'infirmier
infirmière psychiatrique n'existe plus
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça change de
prendre les problèmes psychiques
beaucoup plus tôt dès l'enfance alors
déjà ça change tout en terme de
pronostic c'est-à-dire les les chances
de de de de meilleurs soin voir voir
effectivement de guérison reste entière
les troubles psychopathologiques dans
l'enfance dans l'adolescence euh un
enfant un ados c'est pas un adulte en
miniature c'est un être humain en
devenir donc la prise en charge précoce
permet d'espérer des résultats bien
meilleurs que si on attend trop
et pour cela il faut des moyens de prise
en charge précoce je rappelle que par
exemple les centres
médico-psychologiques les fameux CMP
demandent des délais de plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois parfois
pour la première consultation qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ce qu'a dit le groupe
communiste qui estimé que le rapport de
la mission d'information n'allait pas
assez loin ne répondait pas suffisamment
au CR d'alarme et qui a cité notamment
le professeur David Cohen qui a dit que
la pédopsychiatrie en France et bien
c'était le Tiers Monde oui alors après
au-delà des des formules il y a un
constat effectivement comme je l'ai dit
d'un état plus que préoccupant de la
situation de la pédopsychiatrie après
moi si vous voulez je me suis positionné
surtout en terme de réalisme en terme de
pragmatisme crier un cri pousser un cri
d'alarme c'est bien faire des position
qui pourrait être mise en CH en place
pardon rapidement me paraît mieux que
tomber dans une espèce passzmoin
l'expression je ne veux pas polémiquer
d'incantation sur le sujet très
rapidement faut-il une loi sur ce sujet
sur la pédopsychiatrie pour vous alors
c'est ce que certains demandent une loi
cadre ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
cela sera beaucoup plus lourd à mettre
en place et que les préconisations que
nous avons euh suggéré à travers cette
mission peuvent être mis en place avec
un petit peu de de bonne volonté et
quelques moyens supplémentaires sans
forcément faire tabou rasa du passé et
repartir sur des bases complètement
neuves merci beaucoup Michel Aniel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions voilà
pour cet entretien enregistré un peu
plus tôt cet après-midi et après 9 mois
de travail le Sénat a présenté ses
propositions pour une redresser une
justice qui va mal des pistes de
réflexion à moins de 3 semaines du
premier tour et au lendemain de la
remise d'un livre blanc pour les prisons
ellouise
grégoard 5 ans pour sauver la justice et
le titre du rapport d'information adopté
par la gauche et par la droite
encombrement des dossiers manque de
magistrats et de greffiers palais de
justice vétus et des procédures bien
trop lentes pour le rapporteur de cette
mission la justice va mal les magistrats
sont à la peine les greffiers sont à la
peine il y a un sentiment profond
d'usure et s'il y avait pas la
conscience de servir la justice qui est
une des tâches les plus nobles
dans l'état euh je crois que la justice
aurait craqué aujourd'hui le budget
alloué à la justice est environ à 9
milliards d'euros par an en 2015 il
était à près de 8 milliards la mission
d'information propose une hausse des
moyens de 5 % tout au long du quinquena
moderniser le service public de la
justice en accélérant sa numérisation
rendre plus efficace l'exécution des
peines et 15 nouvelles places de prison
seront également créées mais la
proposition phare de ce rapport est la
création d'un tribunal unique de
première instance par département ce qui
peut changer c'est notamment une
meilleure
organisation départemental un tribunal
de première instance ce qui ne veut pas
dire que tout sera recentré dans le
cheflieu du département on peut garder
les lieux de juridiction qui existent
dans le département et faire en sorte
que la justice soit dans la proximité
mais dans une organisation plus
efficiente pas de hasard ce rapport est
publié à 18 jours de la présidentielle
et compte bien un anc le futur quinena
et justement avant d'en débattre avec
mes invités on va regarder à présent les
propositions des candidats en matière de
justice avec Flora sauvage en matière
d'incarcération Emmanuel Macron et
François Fillon prôent la création
d'environ 15000 places de prison
supplémentair Marine Le Pen vise elle
40000 places d'ici à la fin du quinquena
Benoît amamont et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
préfèrent quant à eux favoriser les
alternatives à la prison partisan d'une
justice qui protège le candidat du
mouvement en marche sou que toutes les
décisions des tribunaux soient
appliquées de manière générale Marine Le
Pen et François Fillon veulent durcir la
justice qu'il jugent trop laxiste en
rétablissant notamment les peines
planché instauré par Nicolas Sarkozi et
supprimé par François Hollande la
présidente du Front national privilégie
désormais la perpétuité réelle au
rétablissement de la peine de mort
Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut quant à lui
réintroduire la police de proximité tout
en désengorgeant les tribunaux sur
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale à 16
ans prené par François Fillon Emmanuel
Macron y est hostile comme Benoît amont
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen
préfère mettre en avant la suppression
des aides sociales aux parents d'enfants
récidivistes enfin sur la question des
moyens pour la sécurité il y a unanimité
tous les candidats veulent augmenter les
effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie et on ouvre tout de suite le
débat avec mes invités sur ce plateau
Hélène Franco bonsoir vous êtes
magistrate vous êtes coanimatrice du
programme justice de la France insoumise
vous soutenez Jean-Luc Mélanchon dans
cette campagne pour la présidentielle
merci d'être avec nous valrend
Saint-Juste est également sur ce plateau
bonsoir vous êtes avocat vous êtes
trésorier du Front National et membre du
conseil stratégique de la campagne de
Marine Le Pen j'accueille également Éric
alfen bonsoir magistrat vous êtes
conseiller à la cour d'appel de Paris
ancien juge antiorruption et vous vous
avez rallié Emmanuel Macron dans cette
course pour la présidentielle et enfin
François Faletti bonsoir vous êtes
l'ancien procureur général de Paris et
vous conseillez vous François Fillon sur
son pro programme pénal on va bien sûr
en parler sur ce plateau et je précise
pour nos téléspectateurs que malgré nos
nombreuses sollicitations aucun membre
de l'équipe de Benoît Hamont n'a pu se
rendre disponible pour ce débat sur la
justice Hélène Franco on vient
d'entendre les sénateurs dans le rapport
ce matin qui font ce constat d'une
justice qui va mal j'imagine que vous le
partagez ce diagnostic quelle en est la
cause selon vous bah absolument alors
j'ai j'ai bien noté que l'actualité pour
le Sénat est essentiellement la justice
pénale pour autant je souhaiteris dire
un mot de la justice dans son ensemble
parce que l'institution judiciaire c'est
d'abord 60 % environ de décisions qui
sont rendues en matière familiale et qui
concne et bien l'ensemble des des
Familles de France potentiellement les
les divorce les séparations les gardes
d'enfants tout ça fait le quotidien de
nos de nos décisions et le quotidien de
nos juridiction et bien c'est une
clochardisation on peut employer ce
terme là une clochardisation matérielle
qui pèse au quotidien sur notre travail
qui fait que nous nous à la France
insoumise nous mettons le rattrapage
budgétaire en premier hein parce que
c'est par là qu'il faudra commencer plus
2 milliards et demi sur l'ensemble du
quinquena et la création de 18000 postes
création net je précise création net de
d'emplois de magistrats et de
fonctionnaires de justice ou on va y
venir dans un instant Fran etti c'est
vrai que c'est cette situation
matérielle hein de la justice qui
inquiète alors il faut absolument
augmenter le budget de la justice ça
vient d'être dit avec Hélène Franco mais
aussi les effectifs c'est aussi ce que
propose François Fillon oui absolument
alors ce qui est proposé au point de vue
budgétaire c'est 15illard 500000 donc
bon en tout cas tout le monde est
d'accord sur la nécessité de de
revaloriser et quand je dis 1 milliard 5
c'est sur les budgets de fonctionnement
hein parce que le problème c'est qu'on a
beaucoup dit que les budgets de la
justice augmentaient au fil des années
mais une bonne partie part à la
pénitentiaire on crée des établissements
pénitentiaire là c'est vraiment sur le
fonctionnement quotidien de la justice
après ça il faut des postes donc 300
j'ai dit magistrat et bien sûr des
postes pour ses aides au magistrats
c'est une chose d'avoir des magistrats
en plus des juges mais si le juge doit
tout faire aller regarder les sites
internet pour regarder la dernière
jurisprudence et cetera non il faut
qu'il ait des appuis des aides et qui
qui assistent dans dans ce travail de
d'élaboration et de préparation c'est
extrêmement important er alfen la
réponse à cette justice qui va mal
est-ce qu'elle peut être seulement mat
selon vous absolument pas c'est vrai
qu'il a il y a toujours la justice et le
parent pauvre du budget de l'État c'est
vrai qui on pourrait mettre un peu plus
de magistrat mais pour moi c'est pas la
question principale déjà en question
d'effectif il s'agit essentiellement
déjà des greffiers et du personnel
éducatif c'est vrai qu'il y a des jus
d'instructions par exemple à Créteil qui
doivent travailler sans greffier tout
simplement parce que ils n'ont pas de
greffier en titre donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a un effort à faire sur les personnels
notamment du GREF pour le reste il faut
tout faire pour rendre la justice plus
indépendante mais aussi mais aussi pas
seulement indépendante il faut qu'elle
soit efficace elle soit surtout plus
transparente c'està dire plus accessible
aux citoyens je pense que les gens ont
beaucoup de défiance vis-à-vis de la
justice et des juges en particulier mais
aussi de la justice parce qu'ils
comprennent mal comment ça marche tout
simplement parfois ils ont une affaire
en cours ils ne savent pas où elle est
où elle en est comment ils vont quand
ils vont être jugés combien ils vont
avoir et cetera et donc notamment par la
numérisation par la numérisation de la
justice justice du citoyen absolument
ben on prévoit notamment la justice de
demain c'estd une justice qui sera
totalement différente de ce qui se passe
les assignations au en matière civile
seront faites en ligne les parties
pourront elles-mêmes s'interroger
répondre en ligne dans la continuité du
quinquenin avec la justice du 21e siècle
le projet de loi qui a déjà été adopté
non non c'est c'est Pasi que ça n'existe
déà par exemple on est toujours obligé
d'envoyer par huissier les assignations
ça fait beaucoup d'argent
quand vous êtes un particulier
transformer le visage de la justice
alors Val
justementêsieurun
présid des élé c'est un des élément non
la numérisation mais c'est un élément on
va venir aux autres éléments justement
par je vais donner la parole à valint
puisque moi il y a une proposition de
Marine Le Pen qui m'a interpellé j'ai vu
qu'elle voulait supprimer l'École
nationale de la magistrature est-ce que
vousir Mar Le Pen a été avocate moi
j'aiété avocat pendant 40 ans et j'ai
professé je professe je vais le dire là
pour pas pour essayer d'élever le débat
je sais pas s que je suis capable mais
un amour immodéré pour l'institution
judiciaire et pour le pouvoir judiciaire
nous pensons et je pense que bon
évidemment il applique la loi il ne fait
pas la loi mais dans un pays le le
pouvoir judiciaire a une place tout à
fait extraordinaire s'il ne fonctionne
pas la société marche très difficilement
s'il fonctionne mieux ou bien les
citoyens vivent de façon beaucoup plus
harmonieuse et je dirais d'ailleurs même
que j'ai toujours eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'admiration pour les magistrats moi qui
n'ai été que je dirais avocat c'estàdire
pour les êtres humains qui se lancent
dans toute la carrière pour plus form
les magistrat Mar AR au nous entendons
et nous souffrons beaucoup des
dysfonctionnements de la justice qui
sont des dysfonctionnements matériels
budgétaires c'est vrai mais aussi des
dysfonctionnements je dirais presque Pol
pourqu suimer le nm Val Saint-Juste oui
alors justement
par exemple c'est quoi les
dysfonctionnem Politi cette école c'est
votre présence sur le plateau c'est
simple c'est la première fois depuis que
je fais de la politique et je suis
avocat que je vois dans le cadre d'une
campagne électorale des magistrats en
exercice venir soutenir des candidats de
façon partisan je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de première fois dans cette
élection B trésor national
so Val donc il a beaucoup de prière fois
avons toujours beaucoup souffert nous
spécialement au Front national mais
c'est pas la question de la politisation
de la justice à l'aide du syndicat fait
pour qu'elle soit indépendante c'est ce
que vous dénoncez aujourd'hui
cementépendante et qu'elle présente par
pitié c'est ça je sais que nous
critiquons souvent fondale la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme mais au
moins elle a conceptualisé vraiment le
caractère objectif du visage de
l'impartialité du magistrat et on ne
veut pas savoir si le magistrat lui-même
est partisan ou pas sectur ou pas on y
arrivera jamais mais il doit montrer et
il ne doit pas venir par exemple sur des
plateaux de télévision pendant une
campagne électorale soutenir de façon
par magistrat moi vous pouvez me donner
toutes les justifications possibles je
suis extrêmement choqué je vais répondre
d'abord c'est pas parce que quelques
magistrats sont engagés que pour autant
la justice dans son ensemble est
politisée et j'attends toujours de votre
part des exemples ça suffit monsie quoi
ça suffit laiss- quelques magistrats je
veux dire on sait très bienors continue
al s'il vous plaît allez-y la
politisation deuxèement deuxièmement les
magistrats sont des citoyens comme les
autres ils ont évidemment des opinions
politiques ce qui compte c'est que dans
le cadre des litiges qu'ils ont à
trancher ils ne sont pas influencé par
ses opinions en ce qui me concerne par
exemple je suis chargé à la chambre
d'instruction des affaires de terrorisme
et des affaires de grande criminalité
organisée je n'ai pas l'impression que
le terrorisme soit de gauche ou de
droite et que la criminalité organisée
soit de gauche ou de droite de sorte que
mon engagement actuel n'influence
absolument pas les décisionsant devant
vous en venant devant vous je n'ai pas
confiance j'ai peur je crains car je
sais que vous avez des opinions
politiques vous ne devriez pas autant
les
montrerite on va avancer sur les
propositionsand prenez les choses à
nominem je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que vous êtes
devant moi c'est que effectivement si
vous êtes injusticiable d'habitude
depuis un certain temps d'abord ce n'est
pas le fait de la justice ou de quelques
magistrats c'est le fait
vraisemblablement d'un certain nombre de
dérives d'ailleurs certaines ont été
admises aujourd'hui par Monsieur
rachelin de votre parti et de dirigeants
de votre parti c'est Monsieur rachelin
lui-même qui a admis avoir bénéficié
d'un emploi fictif à la région Nord pcal
c'est pas LEBAT au' s' vous PLT alors
oui 3 mois ça suffit pour caractériser
quétais en et je
tris sil vous plat
pas
VI représentant du syndicat de la
magistrature candidat
vot je Souha
répond habit
d'interrom simplement le rassurer voz je
vais terminer sur une note plus temp
pour allerond des
CHP téléspectateurs sur les propositions
justiciable doivent savoir qu'il y a une
jurisprudence concernant l'impartialité
c'est une jurisprudence d'ailleurs de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui est appliqué et qui permet aussi au
justicibles qui ont un doute sur
l'impartialité des magistrats de mettre
en œuvre des procédures de récusationis
qu'on VI la formation et au recrutement
des avocats et des magistrats François
Fetti dans le programme de François
Fillon il y a aussi cet aspect de
réforme du recrutement des avocats et
des magistrats ça passe par quoi cette
réforme oui juste quand même parce que
je peux pas rester silencieux moi c'est
vrai que je trouve qu'on a besoin de de
davantage de réserves hein dans le le
fonctionnement de l'institution
judiciaire c'est vrai que les
justiciables les citoyens en fait tout
simplementin quand ils vont devant un
juge ils ont besoin d'être d'avoir la
plus grande confiance dans l'institution
et des affaires comme le mur des con ont
fait un mal mais terrible vous le savez
bien d'ailleurs terrible terrible
monsieur monsieur FTI excusez-moi
excusez-moi respectueusement monsieur
Fetti vous avez fait toute votre
carrière ou judiciaaires dans les
cabinets politiques dans les ministères
dans l'ombre des hommes et des femmes
politiques important de droite et c'est
comme ça que vous êtes retrouvé
procureur général je ne dis pas je dis
pas que vous n'iez
pasal dis simplement que je trouve ça un
peu fort de votre part de parler de
neutralité quand vous avez
é restons là moi je vous dis
simplementérérer mainant au
propositionam en matière de réforme
pénale voilà on sa juste la tolérance
zéro la perpétuité réelle les peines
planchées sont au cœur du programme de
Marine Le Pen est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment applicable aujourd cette
question des pleines planchées
d'ailleurs très intéressante je pense
que nous serons tout à fait en désaccord
céta Nicolas Sarkozi qui les avait
vraiment institué nous étions d'accord
avec lui car nous pensons au Front
national que nous ne devons pas laisser
de l'attitude de trop grande laattitude
au magistrat pour appliquer la peine les
magistrats sont là pour décider de la
culpabilité ça c'est le travail
quelquefois très difficile des
magistrats après en ce qui concerne la
plaine ils doivent être ensérrés dans un
texte et dicté par le législateur qui
représente le peuple et ces peines
planchées doivent être tant en ce qui
concerne surtout en ce qui concerne le
plancher beaucoup plus sévère qu'à
l'heure actuelle mais il ne faut pas de
l'attitude donneré au magistrat vous
aurez les moyens d'appliquer ces
réformes ce que vous proposez cette
tolérance zéro pourquoi est-ce qu'il
n'aurait pas les moyens mais je vous POS
question question de évidemment de
moyens matériels mais de courage
politique et d' instructions qui sont
données par le pouvoir
politique à toute la chaîne par
l'intermédiaire des procureurs généraux
et des procureur de la République ça
c'est le le on sait parfaitement faire
ça au contraire dans le programme de
Jean-Luc Mélanchon il y a cet aspect
d'encourager les alternative à la prison
on voit bien que ce sont deux
philosophies totalement opposé qui qui
s'opposent justement absolument c'est
c'est tout à fait cela ce sont deux
philosophies totalement opposé je vais
en dire quelques mots en 2002 il y avait
dans ce pays 50000 détenus il y en a
aujourd'hui près de 70000 69400 pour
être précise au 1er avril dernier et
pour quel résultat et bien un rapport
tout à fait récent montre que il y a
exactement le double du taux de récidif
pour les personnes qui ont connu la
prison par rapport aux personnes qui ont
eu des peines alternatives à
l'emprisonnement donc la prison
effectivement crée de la récidive et
c'est de la responsabilité de la société
mais aussi de l'intérêt de la société
dans son ensemble que de dével o les
alternatives à l'incarcération de
permettre au service pénitentiire
d'insertion provation non seulement
d'être renforcé considérablement mais
d'être en phase aussi beaucoup plus avec
les systèmes de de droits commun
simplement quand on dit qu'il y a 70000
détenus aujourd'hui à l'heure où nous
parlons et bien imaginez qu'il y a des
enfants de détenus qu'il y a des parents
de détenus qu'il y a des conjoints de
détenus qui eux n'ont rien qui eux n'ont
rien fait et qui se trouvent impacté
directement concerné par l'INC ah Franti
il y a eu ce livre blanc remis par
l'ancien sénateur Jean-René lesser hier
à à jean-jacqu Urvoas lui-même dit
vouloir sortir de la culture du cachot
et on sait que dans ce livre blanc il y
a justement le développement de ces
alternatives à la prison ça a été
rappelé avec un taux de récidive
important aujourd'hui en France François
Fillon au contraire lui il veut
également rétablir les peines planché et
AB baisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
ce qu'on faut sur tout c'est une une
certitude de la peine parce que les
magistrats que que j'ai en face de moi
ça save bien on se trouve très souvent
au tribunal correctionnel avec des
casiers où vous avez 5 6 7 peines
d'emprisonnement avec surcis ça n'a plus
aucun sens au moment où ça tombe ça fait
une avalanche donc il faut oui que quand
on a éventuellement prononcé
l'avertissement du surcis que la fois
suivante et ben ça tombe he c'est c'est
comme ça donc c'est ça cette cette
logique et cette cohérence et c'est ce
qui est voulu moi je rappelle que moi je
voudrais surtout qu'on sorte de
l'idéologie moi j'ai passé monsieur
Alfine a bien fait de rappeler que
j'avais une longue carrière 40 ans en
effet où j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans le
dans le cœur même d'institution
judiciaire on se rend compte que on n
pas voulu regarder les choses en face le
résultat c'est qu'on avait à peu près
45000 places de prison je pense dans les
années 80 on est aujourd'hui à 58000
places or nous avonsis F veut en
construire 16000 hein il en faut 16000
oui mais si vous voulez c'est c'est
c'est indispensable parce que à dire oui
il y a surpopulation mais pourquoi a
surpopulation parce qu'on n pas fait les
efforts d'ajustement en temps utiles et
il y avait des il y a eu des programmes
je suis obligé de dire quand même que
c'est vrai qu'avec le temps quand on
regarde qui construit des des des
prisons ben c'est à certaines époques
certaines majorité voilà et que parfois
les programmes s'arrêtent
donc aujourd'hui moi je je pense que
remonter à 16000 40000 pardonnez-moi je
pense c'est pas réaliste dans un
qu00 para pas réaliste mais 16000 c'est
jouable parce que il faut distinguer les
établissements vous aurez des
établissements classiques disons avec Li
mirador enfin tout ce qu'on connaît mais
aussi des établissements plus plus
légers disons pour des gens qui sont
moins engagés dans le cursus de la
délinquance mais qui ont besoin de la
rupture quand même de la de la de la
sanction qui tombe et donc là on peut on
doit pouvoir arriver il faut y arriver
hein à construire des établissements
mettre des places disponibles qui soient
plus plus simple à à organiser moins
cher au passage et qui permettent
d'apporter des réponses
alfen est-ce que Emmanuel Macron revient
sur la loi tobira et la mise en place de
la contrainte pénale par exemple alors
la contrainte pénale tous les magistrats
savent que ça a pas été appliqué tout
simplement parce que c'était une peine
qui nous semblait à nous magistrats
doublonn un peu avec le sourcil avec
mise à l'épreuve donc je pense qu'il va
falloir trouver d'autres solutions
alternatives plus efficac et plus
appliqué je voudrais dire deux mots
quand même premièrement des peines
planché les peines planchées c'est on se
méfie du magistrat on ne veut pas de lui
et finalement on va le remplacer par un
ordinateur pour le coup on va mettre il
va dit coupable et on va appuyer sur le
bouton et ça va sortir 3 ans de prison
nous au contraire à en marche nous
faisons confiance au magistrat et nous
estimons que les peines qui sont
prononcées par les tribunaux mais par
les tribunaux de façon réfléchie toute
peine prononcée sera exécutée nous pr
parce que nous faisons confiance c'est
vraiment le contrepied de la position
tant du Front national que des
républicains et et de François Fillon
deuxièmement sur les prisons une
politique pénale peut pas se réduire
uniquement à la construction de de place
de prison il en faut effectivement par
exemple puisqu'on parle de prison il y a
des situations absolument inhumaines
dans les prisons il y a eu des rapports
de l'Observatoire des prisons il y a pas
très longtemps et et c'est évident que
il faut aussi reconstruire rénover et
rendre beaucoup plus humaines les
prisons euh sur les les peines
alternatives il faut donner par exemple
moi je trouve qu'il y a un gros problème
c'est notamment les SPIP les services
éducatifs qui n'ont pas de moyens qui
sont souvent pas sur le terrain on parle
souvent par exemple du contrôle
judiciaire mais aux États-Unis quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui est sous
contrôle judiciaire et qu'il a
l'obligation de travailler dès qu'il ne
va pas travailler un matin le contrôleur
judiciaire est sur place il appelle euh
le les les services de justice pour dire
il n'est pas venu travailler en France
les contrôleurs judiciaires les spipes
les services éducatifs sont débordés et
du coup ils ne peuvent pas être sur le
terrain comme ils devrait l'être Hélène
francouandat pe pu prendre la parole
aussi sur la question pr tout à l'heure
monsieur V saint-jus par se candidat oui
euh et je voudrais évidemment aborder ce
thème parce que l'intérêt des victimes
comme l'intérêt de l'ensemble de la
société encore une fois c'est que le
taux de récidive baisse lorsque nous
avons un taux de récidive ça a été
révélé par un un rapport tout récent de
l'ordre de 63 % pour les personnes ayant
connu la détention alors évidemment
c'est très c'est très variable hein
selon les types d'infraction qui ont
abouti à l'emprisonnement il y a
énormément de récidives notamment pour
on est le seul à ne pas vouloir créer de
nouvell plac de de prison absolument
absolument nous nous ne créerons pas de
place de prison suppléa nous rons nous
rénoververons en revanche les les
établissements qui sont totalement
inhumains et dégradants comme celui de
freine comme celui de Villepin puisque
la directrice de Villepin a récemment
tiré je dis simplement que l'intérêt des
victimes comme l'intérêt de toute la
société se se rejoint sur l'idée qu'il
faut lutter contre la récidive prendre
qui marche le travail d'intérêtgénéral
par exemple ça marche pour les mineurs
le la mesure de réparation ça marche en
lien avec les victimes mettre les les
personnes qui ont pu commettre
évidemment des actes pas pas trop trop
grav he Christian tobira lorsqu'elle a
voulu mettre en place cétait rappelé sa
contrainte pénale on a accusé de mettre
en place une justice laxiste Hélène
Franco ben c'est surtout que la
contrainte pénal c'est c'est quelque
chose qui pouvait être intéressant si ça
n'avait pas été aussi aussi complexe
quand même quelque chose d' d' lourd et
complexe alors que nous avons déjà dans
notre arsenal judiciaire des choses qui
doivent être poussés qui doivent être
encouragés je parlais des mesures de
réparation je parlais des des mesures de
travail intergénéral évidemment c'est
pas pour l'ensemble des personnes qui on
des infractions là je parle des des
atteintes au bien essentiellement et
c'est là qu'on a le plus de réci que
propose Marine Le Pen justement pour
lutter contre la récidive écoutez encore
une fois nous allons être totalement
désaccord qu vous vous exprimez cette
culture de l'excuse et du laxisme qui
vous a toujours animé il est faux de
dire que la prison ça ne marche pas ce
qui se passe c'est qu'il y a cette
culture de l'excuse et du lait rappelé
un près de 60
% la prison écoutez sous les les les
gouvernements de droite ou de gauche les
5 ans du cakada de de François Hollande
rien n'a été fait dans les prisons et
j'ai
toujoursi laissez-moi parler laissez-moi
par je pas laissez-moi parler jeis dans
l' les prisons sont la grande honte
française on juge un pays à ses prisons
à l'état de ses prisons et croyez-moi
c'est un scandale permanent évidemment
il faut améliorer tout cela mais quand
les prisons sont humaines lorsque le
principe d'autorité de sévérité y est
euh
respecté moi j'en ai vu énormément dans
ma carrière il y a des prisonniers il y
a beaucoup de prisonniers et il y a la
majorité des gens qui sont sanctionnés
qui en ressortent à amélioré et meilleur
qu'avant et puis la prison a une autre
fonction aussi c'est de mettre hors
d'état de nuire un certain nombre de
délinquants et un certain nombre de
criminels et ça ça vous traverse jamais
dans l'esprit quand vous parlez des
victimes il
fautett et de plus en plus entre mur
pendant 5 10 20 ans c'est ça à quoi ça
sert d'abord je dirais presque la
prison et vos peines
alternatives évidemment rendent la
société c'est extrêmement dangereuse et
extrêmement insécuritaire comme elle est
à l'heure actuelle on juge l'arbre à ses
FRU
50 bien bien on est dans un état
pitoyable sur ce point rapidement moi
moi je crois que incontestablement quand
on nous dit il y a des prisons et c'est
vrai que des prisons qui nous font honte
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
mais c'est encore une fois parce que on
n pas voulu regarder ce problème cette
question en face on a précisément à
cause de l'idéologie qui a fait fait
qu'on disait ah mais il y a quand même
une certaine idéologie anticarcérale or
dans la prison on peut faire du travail
c'est vrai que plus il y a de monde plus
c'est difficile plus c'est compliqué
mais même le rapport du Sénat avec
présenté ce matin par Philippe bal
président de la commission des lois qui
soutient François F surveillant
privilégé aussi cette piste des
alternatives à la
prison personne n'est contre les
alternatives évidemment elles ont elles
ont toutes leur place moi-même quand
j'étais en responsabilité il m'est
arrivait de pousser à mettre en place
des ce qu'on appelle des chantiers
extérieurs c'estàd on fait sortir des
détenus on les fait travailler au
débroussaillement on les fait travailler
on propose dans le programme il y a
cette notion de peine écologique de de
chantier écologique donc d'aller
nettoyer les plages des choses comme
bien évidemment laisser des gens vterer
sur un sur un un lit à regarder la
télévision pendant des jour vous êtes
favorable c'est ce que propose Marine Le
Pen de rattacher l'administration
pénitentiaire au ministère de
l'Intérieur François Faletti euh oui oui
c'est je pense que il y a un problème
voyezour au 19e siècle non mais je crois
qu' y a une certaine logique une
certaine cohérence dans dans dans ce qui
concerne les forces de sécurité on voit
bien qu'accompagner des détenus c'est
pas une affaire simple et il y a une
certaine cohérence dans dans cela il y a
une cohérence aussi dans le fait que le
ministère de la Justice je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure quand on dit qu'il y a une
augmentation du budget du ministère de
la Justice il y en a la moitié souvent
et c'est très légitime qui part la pour
la pénitentière et donc c'est en
trompleœil Eric alfen et ça sera le mot
de la fin à propos des prisons je
voudrais juste dire un mot le problème
nouveau c'est quand même celui des des
terroristes qui sont en prison h et
c'est vrai que on y réfléchit beaucoup
chez Emmanuel Macron on on a mis au
point le fait que il fallait des petites
structures avec les gens radicalisés qui
sont autreux pour éviter la contagion de
la radicalisation parce qu'on voit
souvent des des jeunes qui sont là-bas
qui au départ n'étaient pas radicalisés
et qui nous ont expliqué comment les
caïdes du terrorisme ont fait pression
pour eux sur eux pour qu'ils changent
donc c'était un mot que je voulais dire
sur les prisons par ailleurs on n' pas
du tout parlé de la proposition de
majorité pénale à
euh nous trouons nous trouvons en de la
spécif la spécificité pardon de la
justice des mineurs c'est juste que les
mineurs peuvent bénéficier de l'excuse
de minorité qui peut réduire de moitié
leur peine sauf que déjà les magistrats
et il l'appliquent très souvent ont la
possibilité pour les mineurs de 16 ans
de passer outre cette excuse de minorité
et deuxièmement donc c'est c'est inutile
faut motiver il faut motiver mais c'est
pas très compliqué pour un magistrat
d'arriver à motiver et et et
deuxièmement euh contrairement à ce qui
est dit il y a beaucoup de mineurs qui
sont en prison et enfin la question de
la constitutionnalité de cette mesure se
pose puisque il y
a la Convention nationale internationale
relative au droit de l'enfant qui dit
que la majorité c'est 18 ans et donc
c'est
trèsile de minorité nous abaissement de
la majorité P nous le proposions nous le
proposons plus car c'est vrai que ça
c'est un point qui doit êre à sera
l'occasion de rouvrir le débat sur ce
point merci François valtis mercil
Franco merci B saint-j merci beaucoup
mot de gauche et droite merci à tous les
quatre c'est la fin de ce débat on va on
va continuer on va continuer cette
émission et je vous propose et bien de
retourner au Parlement européen à
Strasbourg il a été question aujourd'hui
et bien du brexit et des négociations on
pourra en parler on va retrouver Nora
Amadi c'est notre journaliste
spécialiste des questions européennes
elle était au côté de laeurodéputé
pervanche BES écoutez
oui Delphine je suis effectivement avec
pervanche BZ donc député socialiste donc
de la délégation française c'est elle
qui a suivi ce dossier pour la
délégation française alors pervanche BES
516 voix pour 133 contre 50 abstentions
c'est une résolution assez ferme qui a
été voté ici donc ce midi l'idée face
cette négociation face à cette
négociation ha risque qui s'annonce dans
le brexit c'est qu'il fallait faire
front uni ou punir carrément le
Royaume-Uni non moi comme je je pense la
grande majorité de ceux qui ont voté
cette résolution j'étais contre le
brexit parce que je pense pas que ce
soit une bonne nouvelle ni pour le
Royaume-Uni ni surtout pour l'Union
européenne mais maintenant le brexit est
là madame Teresa met a envoyé les
instruments de l'article 50 elle
confirme que le Royaume Unis ne veut pas
être partie du marché intérieur ne veut
pas respecter les quatre libertés du
marché intérieur liberté de circulation
des biens des personnes des capitaux et
des services elle ne veut pas contribuer
au budget de l'Union européenne elle ne
veut pas de la compétence de la Cour de
justice et elle veut pouvoir négocier
ses propres accords commerciaux la
question n'est pas de savoir si on
rentre dans un brexit dur ou pas dur la
question est de savoir sur la base de
ces éléments comment est-ce que l'Union
européenne négocie et de ce point de
vue-là l'Union européenne doit être
claire on ne peut pas être dedans et
dehors il y a des règles il y a un
traité et c'est cela qu'il faut mettre
en œuvre cette réseau résolution
j'espère qu'elle inspirera les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement puisque nous
sommes la première institution à nous
prononcer et nous le faisons je trouve
avec clarté et
fermeté durant le débat qui s'est
déroulé tout toute cette matinée
beaucoup de chefs de groupe beaucoup de
parlementaires ont dit qu'il fallait
profiter de cette sortie de des
Britanniques de l'Union européenne pour
réorienter l'Europe qu'est-ce qu'il faut
craindre si ce n'est pas le cas c'est
l'effet dominau c'est qu'il y ait
d'autres brexit je crois que le départ
du Royaume-Uni euh signe la fin d'une
certaine façon de concevoir l'Union
européenne d'ailleurs souvenez-vous
David Cameron lorsqu'il était Premier
ministre ne parlait jamais de l'Union
européenne il disait le marché unique et
c'était une conception de l'Union
européenne qui n'est pas adaptée à la
réalité des défis que l'Union européenne
elle-même a apporté car ces défis sont
d'abord de nature politique comment
est-ce qu'on met en uvre des concepts de
solidarité face à la flu de réf jet
comment est-ce qu'on met en œuvre cette
solidarité alors qu'il y a une monnaie
unique dont on voit que tous les outils
ne sont pas en place est-ce que on
profite oui ou non de ce brexit de cette
négociation pour clarifier la façon dont
fonctionne l'Union européenne je crois
que c'est un rendez-vous extraordinaire
finalement un rendez-vous extraordinaire
qu'il ne faut pas rater sinon le risque
c'est quoi c'est l'implosion de l'Union
oui et je crois que ça sera dans
l'intérêt de personne mais vous savez
pour que l'Union européenne fonctionne
bien
il faut que les États-membres
fonctionnent bien d'où l'importance que
chacun lorsqu'il va se déterminer dans
l'élection présidentiel en France et
conscience de la du mandat qu'il donnera
au prochain chef de l'état de la France
car 15 jours après l'élection ce chef
d'État aura à négocier avec ses
partenaires le
mandat pour la négociation avec les
Britanniques merci beaucoup pervanche BZ
d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci beaucoup Nora comme tous
les mercredis on s'intéresse à présent à
la campagne vue du terrain et
aujourd'hui des bons lieux où le taux
d'abstention atteint des records dans le
quartier du neof à Strasbourg des
associations refusent d'admettre cette
fatalité et se mobilise pour inciter les
gens à aller voter reportage de Cécile
Sixou avec Géraldine baboilo bonjour
nous sommes ici à neof dans la banlieue
de Strasbourg un quartier connu pour ces
voitures qui brûlent le soir de la
sintyvet
ici les taux de chômage atteignent des
records 25 % des habitants ne
travaillent pas alors comment dans ces
territoires Viton et voit-on la campagne
présidentielle nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ses habitants pour en
[Musique]
parler c'est de faire baisser le taux
d'abstention dans le quartier convaincre
les habitants de son quartier de voter
c'est le combat de Jamila et le fait de
se déplacer pour aller voter blanc ça
voudrait dire que dans le quartier voilà
on sait il est où le bureau de vote
pourquoi tu vas pas voter j'ai 21 ans ch
du travail je trouve pas parce qu' il y
a personne qui nous aide nous les jeunes
pour chercher du travail ben justement
un président ou un maire ça sert à ça
choqué par les taux d'abstention de 80 %
aux dernières élections elle a lancé
avec les jeunes du
un challenge pour inciter les habitants
à se rendre aux urnes le 23 avril
prochain est-ce que vous pouvez me
parler un petit peu de ce challenge
citoyen que vous avez mis en place donc
c'est un concours lancé à tous les
quartiers de France qui a pour but de
faire baisser le taux d'abstention on
s'est réuni de de de octobre à décembre
pour toquer à 4000 portes du quartier
pour déjà d'un dans un premier temps les
informer qu'il faut s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales avant le 31 décembre
donc 2016 et on on offrait aussi la
possibilité de s'inscrire directement
avec nous au pied de de de leur immeuble
donc ils avaient juste à descendre et
nous retrouver en bas et ils pouvaient
également venir au centre avec leurs
documents s'ils avaient du des problèmes
à remplir on les aidait voilà mais
justement vous vous réunissz avec les
jeunes du challenge citoyen moi je vous
suis on va participer à cette réunion
dans le quartier grâce au challenge
citoyen 600 personnes ont pris leur
carte électorale petite victoire pour
l'équipe de Jamila qui reste mobilisée
jusqu'à l'élection
bonjour
bonjour les personnes qui savent pas où
ils vont devoir aller voter selon leur
adresse donc vous allez devoir voir
selon voilà comment le territoire est
coupé pour qui va votter où comme ça
vous pouvez les renseigner quel document
il faut avoir et bien sûr lesah les
programmes des candidats vous avez déjà
fait du porte à porte pour pour pousser
un peu les gens à s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales qu'est-ce que vous
avez eu comme retour des gens enfin
c'est quoi vos impressions des personnes
qui nous ont ouvert leurs porte ils
étaient c'était des
personnes chaleureuse éta accueillante
et mais ils aimaient discuter ils
voulaient pas voter et d'autres
personnes on a réussi à les convaincre
parce que au début il dis ils étaient
rétisant ils voulaient pas aller voter
ils ont dit ouais mais si je vote pour
le mauvais comment ça va se passer pour
mes enfants ils étaient ils avaient peur
pour leurs enfants et vous vous gagnez
quoi si vous gagnez le challenge qu'on a
qu'on a mobilise des gens un T
d'abstention qui a diminué des gens sont
allés voter même si c'est blanc des gens
ont quand même fait le déplacement
redonner l'envie de participer à la vie
politique le défi est compliqué pour ces
jeunes face à eux beaucoup ne se sentent
pas concerné trop loin souvent exclus
socialement sur les 20000 habitants que
compte le neof un/art sont au chômage il
y a un taux de chômage particulièrement
élevé ici au neof est-ce que le fait
aussi d'être connecté du monde du
travail ça joue pas sur cette
déconnexion
politique bien sûr ça joue ça joue
énormément effectivement puisque dans
ces quartiers là à l'époque il y avait
la classe ouvrière qui était active qui
avait voilà qui avait une idéologie de
classe tout ça c'est totalement
désagrégé aujourd'hui les grands cadres
les grands corps sociaux n'existent plus
et chacun est laissé un peu est laissé
un peu effectivement et tout notre
travail c'est de leur dire vous êtes
porteur de possible et vous pouvez faire
les choses et dans toutes lesestrades de
la structure donc on commence on
accueille une population de 4 à plus de
99 ans et dès l'âge de 4 ans on dit aux
gens qu'ils sont importants qu' leur VO
compte c'est important de faire ça de de
donner de l'ambition aux jeunes on leur
fait des ouvertures sur des possibles et
on leur propose des activités qu'il
n'auraient jamais imaginé parce qu'il
voilà parce qu'ils ont une histoire qui
qui ne leur permet pas de
deimaginer des choses nouvelles on leur
ouvre voilà des des nouvell F lettre sur
sur le
[Musique]
monde ouvrir les portes du monde du
travail aux jeunes du noof les sortir
des clichés des banlieux voilà aussi
comment se joue ici l'avenir du rapport
aux
[Musique]
politique et on va de nouveau retrouver
Cécile sixsou cette fois au côté de la
sénatrice LR du Barin Fabiane Keller
quel regard porte-t-elle sur cette
initiative du challenge citoyen on l'a
vu dans le reportage le travail des
associations est assez intensif pour
faire participer les gens aux élections
qu'est-ce que vous les pouvoir public
vous pouvez faire pour pour lutter
contre l'abstention alors l'action du
centre social et culturel du N est
formidable c'est vrai que les jeunes ont
une énergie et ils ont su la la
mobiliser pour donner envie à travers ce
clip de d'aller
voter la République est très loin de
hein euh donc parfois ils ont le
sentiment d'avoir reçu beaucoup de
promesses et qui les réalisations ont
pas toujours été à la hauteur donc ils
ont besoin de nous nous voir hein ils
sont un peu comme Saint- Thomas voilà il
ne croit que ce qu'il voit et donc
j'aime beaucoup venir ici discuter voilà
je je suis venu un peu à l'avant
l'interview pour avoir le temps de
prendre un café de rencontrer des gens
ils sont heureux de me revoir en plus il
y a un beau soleil c'est euh c'est comme
ça qu'on peut montrer le respect et du
coup être en cohérence avec un
engagement républicain est-ce que vous
trouvez qu'on en parle assez des
banlieux dans cette campagne
présidentielle alors moi j'ai fait
campagne avec Alain Jupé on a fait
l'urne des quartier on a tourné d'un
quartier à l'autre hein j'ai fait
moi-même une dizaine de sites avec
l'idée qu'il fallait les encourager à
prendre la parole on a fait un beau
travail de synthèse je pense que une des
démarches comme cela permettent au aux
habitants des quartiers de se sentir
pleinement associé à cette démarche
voilà un peu qui passe à la télé qui
peut sembler très éloignée de ce qu'ils
vivent au au quotidien c'est un enjeu
majeur parce que ce sont des citoyens
ils ont de l'énergie ils ont de la
volonté donc il faut qu'ils puissent
être associé aux décisions qui les
concernent merci beaucoup Fabien KCI à
vous d'être venu au
mer action de Fabiane Keller enregistré
cet après-midi ABA wessi et notre invité
aujourd'hui c'est le président duub du
21e siècle et il répond aux questions de
Saveria rojc le face- à faceace c'est
tout de
suite
Abi bonjour bonjour vous êtes avocat
président du club 21e siècle est-ce que
vous pouvez d'abord nous expliquer quel
est le rôle de ce club oui alors merci
de votre invitation le club 21e siècle
est un club qui a été créé en 2004 qui
œuvre pour une vision positive de
l'égalité des chances de la diversité et
du mérite républicain alors concrètement
on a deux types d'action on a une action
d'influence auprès des décideurs
économiques politiques et dans le
domaine des médias et puis on a une
deuxième action qui est celle de
l'accompagnement de talent de potentiel
dont on parle pas assez malheureusement
dans notre pays aujourd'hui
accompagnement de jeunes entrepreneurs
de jeunes étudiants et on essaie de
mettre en avant et bien des parcours
exemplaires et il y en a un très grand
nombre dans notre pays et donc notre
rôle c'est de révéler ces talents au
plus au plus grand public et c'est ce
qu'on fait dans diff différentes
opérations est-ce que vous jugez que
l'ascenseur social aujourd'hui est
bloqué en France l'ascenseur social il
est en panne c'est évident et il est en
panne pour plusieurs raisons alors elles
sont économiques d'abord elles sont
aussi politiques parce que moi j'en veux
en particulier à nos hommes politiques
qui malheureusement ont oublié le sujet
de l'égalité des chances dans leur
discours dans leur présentation dans
aussi leurs actions économiquees parce
qu'il y a un véritable problème aussi de
chômage qui est assez endémique on le
voit sur les territoires notamment en
banlieu le chômage des jeunes il est
très important et il est encore plus
important quand on a un prénom à
consonance étrangère ce qui est pas
normal dans ce pays pays l'égalité des
pays de des droits de l'homme notamment
pays qui a connu Victor Hugo Voltaire
montesquieux et cetera et qui
aujourd'hui Ben se voit avec deux France
l'une à côté de l'autre des concitoyens
qui se regardent un petit peu en chien
faillance un rejet de l'autre un repli
sur soi et tout ce contexte là fait
qu'il y a l'ascenseur sociale qui à mon
sens véritablement panoui aujourd'hui la
France est encore un pays de cast alors
je sais pas si on peut utiliser le terme
cast mais en tout cas c'est un pays de
l'entre soi pour beaucoup je vais vous
donner un exemple très concret nous on
reçoit au club 21e siècle l'ensemble des
dirigeants d'entreprise par exemple et
souvent quand on les interroge sur leur
politique égalité des chances leur
politique diversité il nous disent bah
écoutez c'est bien moi je fais ceci
telle et telle chose et quand on leur
pose juste la question ben dans votre
conseil d'administration combien
avez-vous de femmes combien avez-vous de
profil F issu de la diversité la réponse
est bien souvent zéro et donc
effectivement on a même au plus haut
sommet de l'entreprise un entre soi par
réflexe on recrute toujours les mêmes on
a toujours les mêmes administrateurs or
justement ce qu'on essaie de ce qu'on
essaie de briser c'est ce plafond de
vert et c'est cet entre soi qui mine
véritablement la société qui est un
facteur aussi de désespoir pour beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui s'autocensur en
se disant bah tes entreprises c'est pas
fait pour moi je vais pas y postuler
parce que les dirigeants quels que
soient mes diplômes quels que soient mes
compétences me reconnaîtront pas en
fonction de ce que je suis mais ils me
reconnaîtront uniquement en fonction de
ce que je paraît être c'est là le
travail à justement vous proposez des
initiatives concrètes aux entreprises
aux grandes entreprises notamment le
mentoring le mentoring en entreprise
c'estd des entreprises qui détachent des
employés pour ensuite coacher des jeunes
c'est ça exactement alors on a la chance
d'avoir au club 21e siècle des des des
membres qui sont de grande qualité qui
ont d'importantes fonctions et qui
donnent de leur temps pour justement
accompagner des jeunes et parmi nos
membres on a des membres qui ont créé
des associations nationale tel que
mosaïque herche avec saamouche Nos
Quartiers ont des Talents avec yzitchir
ou encore Passeport Avenir avec Benjamin
Blavier ou ou Fratelli et ces
associations elles ont un avantage c'est
qu'elles ont la chance de pouvoir avoir
des milliers de jeunes qui ne demandent
qu'une chose c'est être accompagné donc
au club 21e siècle on accompagne ces
jeunes mais aussi on incite tous nos
partenaires sponsors entrepris à faire
de même c'estàd à faire en sorte que
leurs collaborateurs donnent de leur
temps c'est pas beaucoup c'est 1h 2h par
mois mais cette heure ou ces 2 heures
par mois vont permettre à des jeunes qui
sont étudiants qui sont jeunes
entrepreneurs de retrouver confiance en
eux de créer du lien de vouloir aussi
redonner à la République ce qu'elle leur
a donné c'està-dire la chance de pouvoir
étudier dans ce beau pays donc c'est le
travail d'accompagnement de talent de
potentiel que l'on met en avant au club
21e siècle alors la liversité c'est un
thème qui est plus plutôt absent he de
la campagne présidentielle je sais que
vous avez rencontré toutes les équipes
des candidats quel est candidat qui
étaient le plus réceptif réceptif à vos
initiativ à vos idées à vos propositions
alors peut-être que comme moi vous avez
regardé le débat d'hier soir qui a qui
s'est terminé justement qu'avez-vous
pensé du débat qui s'est terminé vers
minuit moi j'étais affligé et atterré de
ce débat là pour une raison très simple
c'est que on sait non seulement c'était
assez confus mais en plus nos
concitoyens 40 % des Français ont au
moins un grand pè ou une grand-mère qui
est d'origine étrangère B ces 40 % de
Français n'ont pas été cités n'ont pas
été évoqués lors de ces débat qui a duré
quand même près de 4 He donc vous avez
une partie de la société française qui
ne se reconnaît pas dans ces 11
candidats qui les ont complètement
occulté et oublié voulez dire
l'intégration de ces Français dans la
société française tout simplement ils
sont intégrés ce sont des Français mais
des Français qui non mais qu'est-ce qui
n'a pas été évoqué l'inté la diversité
n'a pas été évoqué l'égalité des chances
le mérite républicain l'espoir que
chacun d'entre nous att justement vous
qui avez rencontré les candidats et les
équipes des candidats euh qui est le
plus réceptif à ces idées alors on a
rencontré tous les candidats à la
présidentielle en tout cas une grande
partie d'entre eux et surtout on discute
avec l'ensemble des équipes de campagne
puisque c'est le travail d'influence du
club 21e siècle et il y en a
effectivement qui sont plus réceptifs
que d'autres il y a des bonnes mesures
chez certains candidats qui proposent de
diviser les classes en primaire dans les
banlieux par deux il y a certains
candidats euh qui proposent notamment de
créer une instance telle que euh
l'instance de répression euh contre la
fraude euh et notamment cette instance
serait une une sorte d'inspection du
travail chargé de lutter contre les
discriminations et ça c'est une bonne
proposition mais il y en a d'autres qui
sont pas réceptifs moi je regrette par
exemple que certains candidats et bien
ne souhaite absolument pas discuter de
la diversité et de l'égalité des chances
donc c'est très variable nous on a un
véritable travail d'influence que l'on
mène mais il y a aussi au niveau des
candidats je pense un manque de prise de
conscience de la nécessité de créer du
lien entre tous nos concitoyens très
bien merci beaucoup on a entendu votre
message merci beaucoup merci vous merci
vous merci beaucoup on va revenir à
présent sur ce débat inéit à la
télévision véritable exercice
démocratique mais pas forcément en gage
de qualité alors avant d'en débattre
avec mes invités retour sur les temps
forts avec Fabrice cunet sur la base de
ce texte constitutionnel et bien nos
mares pourront malgré encore une fois
l'interdiction que veut promulguer
monsieur barroin dans le et bien voilà
alorsoulez mettre des symboles religieux
dans les maies c'est V
truc
religieux laité ce sont nos traditions
Monsieur Mélenchon je sais qu'elle vous
dérangeis même qu' hor peutre j'ai une
Mo mais c'est chez moi j'ête pas tout le
monde avec qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
président exemplaire c'est d'abord un
président qui dit la vérité aux Français
sur la réalité de la France et la
réalité du monde un président exemplaire
c'est un président qui met en œuvre les
engagements qu'il a pris devant le
peuple quel que soi les difficultés un
président exemplaire c'est un président
qui respecte son premier ministre et qui
respecte le gouvernement et qui respecte
l'équilibre des pouvoir prévu par la
Constitution Fillon voilà il est en face
de moi que des histoires et plus on
fouille plus plus on sent la corruption
plus on sent la triche et à côté de ça
donc en plus c'est des bonhommes qui qui
qui nous expliquent qu'il faut la
rigueur qu'il faut l'austérité et eux
même ils piquent dans les caisse
publique donc il y a quand même un petit
problème de ce côté-là après vous pouvez
parler non monsieur F vous pourvez
parler après oui non d'accord ou merci
euh donc bon c'est ce que j'ai dit je
l'ai dit euh ensuite il y a aussi Le Pen
hein à côté alors va peut-être réagir
aussi mais Le Pen pareil on pique dans
les caisses publiques alors là c'est pas
c'est pas ici c'est l'Europe alors
l'Europe pour quelqu'un qui est
anti-européen ça ça vienne pas de piquer
de l'argent de l'Europe et le pire c'est
qu'en plus le FN qui se dit antiystème
ne s'emmerde pas du tout se protège
grâce aux lois du système grâce à à à
l'immunité parlementaire et donc refuse
d'aller aux convocations policières donc
pénard donc là tout ça ça illustre la ça
ça illustre ouais quand nous on est
convoqué par la police nous ouvyez par
exemple on a pas d'immunité ouvrière
désolé on y va ce que vous proposez
c'est la guerre économique et nous ne
sommes ni la Suisse ni la Corée du Sud
Madame Le Pen la réalité de notre vie
économique c'est que ce seront des
destructions d'emploi ce que vous
proposez c'est le le nationalisme moi je
viens d'une région où les conflit entre
justement les pays d'Europe qui et Jean
Lassal l'a très bien rappelé il faut
savoir d'où on VI et où cette séparation
nous ramènera le nationalisme c'est la
guerre moi je veux bien que tout le
monde ait un schéma en tête disant je
vais montrer les muscles et puis si ça
bouge pas on sortira peut-être mais que
se passe-t-il derrière parce que plan a
plan B c'est très intéressant mais c'est
quoi le plan C enre cas le plan pour les
français derrière en matière d'inflation
en matière d'emploi en matière de dette
moi en tout cas je préfère avoir
aujourd'hui la remise en cause de
l'austérité parce qu'elle est en train
de disloquer l'Europe mais construire
l'Europe et continuer à parier sur les
la coop tion parce que demain pas
d'Europe c'est la compétition à tout va
la compétition à tout va et ça je l'ai
pas entendu
ça et pour décrypter ce débat mes
invités sur ce plateau Jean Alimi
bonsoir vous êtes rédactrice en chef
adjointe au service politique du
Parisien merci d'être avec nous
également sur ce plateau Philippe maau
Chevrolet bonsoir communiquant président
de mcbg conseil j'accueille également
Thierry Vedel bonsoir politologue et
chercheurs au CNRS et au CV merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation Erwan
LAN est également avec nous directeur
d'études à l'institut BVA opinion merci
à tous les quatre on va également parler
dans ce débat avec vous Tam des erreurs
qui ont pu être prononcées he par les
candidats il y en a eu beaucoup et
notamment sur les chiffres du chômage et
oui à croire que les candidats aiment
bien gonfler les chiffres du chômage
pour servir leurs arguments hier bien il
y a d'abord eu François Fillon qui a
parlé de 6 millions de chômeurs de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique et
bien Philippe Poutou lui aussi a repris
ce chiffre de 6 millions de chômeurs une
exagération puisque la catégorie A les
personnes sans aucune activité dont on
parle quand on parle de chômeurs
généralement et bien c'est seulement 3
millions et demi de personnes si vous
rajoutez les catégories B et C
c'est-à-dire les personnes à temps
partiel qui veulent travailler plus vous
atteignez 5,4 millions de personnes et
si vous ajoutez les catégories D et E
sur les personnes qui ne sont pas tenues
de chercher un emploi donc qui par
définition ne sont pas au chômage vous
atteignez 6 millions et demi de
personnes exagérer les chiffres du
chômage et bien c'est un classique lors
du premier débat sur TF1 Marine Le Pen
elle avait parlé de 7 millions de
chômeurs encore plus loin de la vérité
c'est un festival d'approximation sur
les effectifs des militaires aussi Tam
et oui selon Marine Le Pen justement et
bien les effectifs de militairees ont
baissé de 54000 personnes sous François
Fillon Nicolas dupoignant lui parle de
40000 militaires sur la même période
alors qui dit vrai et bien en réalité
c'est seulement 32000 postes de militair
qui ont disparu alors c'est tout de même
près de 44000 si on inclut les civils
mais si vous regardez les documents du
ministère de la défense ils font bien la
différence he entre les militaires et
les civils on peut tout consulter sur
leur site internet en revanche il est
exact que les effectifs militaires ont
fondu de 20000 personnes entre 2012 et
2015 reste que la baisse des effectifs
militaires et bien c'est fini depuis
2015 depuis les attentats terroristes et
même les effectifs augmentent petit à
petit ouais on va rester sur les
questions de défense avec la proposition
d'Emmanuel Macron d'instaurer une
cellule auprès auprès du président de la
République pour suivre en permanence les
informations sur daesh et ceux qui
peuvent nous menacer et oui l'art de
réinventer quelque chose qui existe déjà
le candidat dans marche propose donc ce
qu'il existe donc un coordinateur
national durant saement ça existe depuis
2008 depuis quelques mois c'est le
préfet Yann junau il travaille donc
auprès de François Hollande il élabore
des notes quotidiennes d'informations
sur la situation notamment terroriste
dans le monde il dispose d'une dizaine
de conseiller il est aussi responsable
du Conseil national de renseignement les
dernière information que vous avez
vérifié qui s'avère également fausse
c'est celle qui concerne François Fillon
il a déclaré que la déchance de
nationalité était une mesure du Front
populaire et c'est une intoxe et une
intoxe qu'il n'utilise pas pour la
première fois il avait déjà fait cette
référence lors de l'émission politique
sur France 2 il y a une quinzaine de
jours la déchéance de nationalité elle
existe bien depuis 1938 le décret loi
date très exactement du 12 novembre 38
seulement alors et bien Léon Bloom n'est
plus président du conseil c'est D
radical qui est président du conseil
pour être tout à fait complet à l'époque
et bien Daladier ne bénéficie plus du
soutien des communistes les radicaux ont
quitté les comités du Front populaire et
un mois plus tard d'ailleurs Daladier et
bien est rallié par la droite et
notamment la droite la plus
réactionnaire j'ajoute que le contexte
et bien c'est celui de l'approche de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale la la pardon
Hitler au pouvoir la guerre civile
espagnole et à l'époque et bien
lorsqu'on parle de déchéance de
nationalité on pense surtout aux espions
et pas aux terroristes merci beaucoup
Tam on va poursuivre le débat avec mes
invités jeannickami sur le plan
politique qu'avez-vous retenu de ce
débat est-ce que vous pensez que ça
débat dont la forme était très
contrainte à 11 candidats on l'a rappelé
c'était inédit ça a pu permettre de
faire émerger une personnalité en tout
cas ça a fait mieux connaître ces petits
candidats dont on pense ce qu'on veut
qui sont inutiles qui perturbent le
débat qu'ils apportent des solutions ou
en tout cas des propositions
complètement UBS qui n'empêche qu'ils
existent he constitutionnellement ils
sont là ils représentent entre 5 et 8 %
je pense hein de l'électorat donc à ce
titre- làà c'était bien de les avoir
parce que pour eux c'était un véritable
enjeu de connaissance et de et de
reconnaissance euh quant au au plus
grands candidats alors je je ne sais pas
si on va parler des programmes des
lignes politiques en tout cas je pense
que sur le plan de de l'identité si je
puis dire des individualités si tantit
qu'il y avait encore des ambiguités des
flous euh des des connaissances
approximatives des uns et des autres bah
ce type de débat même contraint mais
tout de même assez long euh dans la
durée a permis de mieux je pense hein
pour les téléspectateurs plus de 6
millions hein je crois de de mémoire de
mieux camper c'est pas mal de mieux
camper les personnalités des cinq plus
grands dans l'arène ouais d'autant que
c'est le seul un débat puisqueon a
appris et bien que France 2 renoncé à
organiser le débat qui était prévu le 3
jours avant le scrutin le 20 avril
c'était une tribune pour ces petits
candidats qui ont eu leur moment de
gloire Philippe ma chevolet oui tout le
monde a eu ces 15 minutes de de gloire
c'est le cas de le dire puisque
effectivement il 15 minutes de temps de
parole c'est très voir au lien c'est
très voir au lien chacun eu son moment
alors c'était intéressant parce qu'au
fond les Français avaient envie de C de
cette confrontation à 11 on sent que le
casting des cinq principaux candidats ne
convainc pas forcément il y a beaucoup
d'indécis on sait beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes annoncés donc ils
avaient envie de voir tous les candidats
et puis après tout tous les candidats
étaient qualifiés démocratiquement avec
500 signatures dans le cas de Jean
Lassal c'est même plus de 700 signatures
donc il représente lui les communes
d'ailleurs il a défendu ça sur le
plateau il était venu pour ça en quelque
sorte c'est la politique tel qu'on
l'aime il y a de la mauvaise foi il y a
des coubas il y a des gueulards il y a
des papis qui nous assent des vérités
qui sont très douteuses à partir de fait
historiques très anciens dont personne
ne se
souvient c'est un repas de famille en
fait on partage un repas de famille avec
eux et au fond c'est pas mal parce qu'on
voit effectivement les personnalités on
voit aselino prendre le dessus sur
Emmanuel Macron à un moment donné ce qui
est incroyable on voit Emmanuel Macron
qui est sauvé par Marine Le Pen à un
autre moment pour qui dit ben non il
doit débattre avec du pontaignan du
ponignan qui se dit mais pourquoi Marine
Le Pen m enfin c'est c'est marrant quoi
mais ça rajoute pas un peu de confusion
justement contraire ça les Français à
faire leur choix on n pas eu de campagne
on n pas eu de campagne il y a pas eu de
thème il y a pas eu de débat sur le fond
on a parlé que des affaires et de
l'argent de François fillan on sort
enfin dans autre chose pourant ouais et
pourtant les affaires étaient très
présentes Thierry Vedel qu'avez-vous
pensé de ce débat justement c'était pas
vraiment un gage de qualité hein cette
forme 11 candidats 17 minutes pour
s'exprimer bah le le format est
extrêmement difficile surtout s'il en a
11 candidats et puis bon moi je crois
quand même qu'il va falloir revoir un
jour jour ou l'autre le le processus de
sélection à la campagne officielle hein
parmi les candidats parce que le système
des parinages pose quand même quelques
problèmes et puis ensuite si on va avoir
un vrai débat là on a quoi on a quand
même la juste apposition de monologue
avec de temps en temps quelques
interpellations ou quelques
altercation donc ça rend difficile quand
même l'information après faut savoir ce
qu'on recherche on a dit 6 millions plus
de 6 millions de téléspectateurs c'est à
la fois beaucoup et pas beaucoup c'est à
la fois beaucoup par rapport à aux
audiences habituelles des émissions
politique qui sont souvent plus proches
des 1 million voire inférieur mais c'est
aussi peu par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'électorat 46 million d'électeurs donc
ça veut dire 40 millions d'électeurs
n'ont pas vu le
débat donc et on sait aussi qu'on a à
faire un public plutôt politisé plus
politisé que la moyenne des des des
téléspectateurs en général ouis
herwanroant est-ce que ça permis
certainement de faire aussi bouger les
lignes notamment chez les indécis qui ne
savent pas encore pour qui ils vont
voter au premier tour mais c'est la
question qu'on pourrait se poser quand
on interrogait les Français avant le
débat ils avaient des attentes
démocratiques fortes à l'égard de ce
débat et des attentes un peu dopées par
le fait que maintenant on avait 11
candidats donc c'est ce qui apparaissait
comme le moment démocratique un peu fort
du du débat de la campagne et ce qui
remontait c'était on veut maintenant que
ça dépasse les questions d'alliance les
questions de stratégie politicienne les
questions d'affaires et qu'on aille
vraiment sur le fond et qu'on aborde les
programmes qu'on nous donne un peu une
vision de l'avenir qu'on nous rassure
sur la capacité à comprendre nos
préoccupations c'est ce qui remontait de
nos enquêtes dans ce contexte finalement
il y a eu deux parties dans le débat on
interrogait les français de façon
qualitative en fait pendant le débat et
il y a eu deux deux parties finalement
une première partie où c'est les petits
qui ont un peu volé la vedette au gros
et une première moitié du débat où on a
découvert avec curiosité avec amusement
avec sarcasme les petits candidats
Philippe Poutou françoiselino Jacques
Cheminade et une deuxième partie
finalement on s'est recentré sur les
gros candidats et sur la question de de
leur programme et de leur ligne un peu
discordante sur les les grandes mesures
et c'est là où c'est finalement assez
intéressant parce qu'on a vu qu'il y a
des lignes qui ont probablement bougé
aujourd'hui quand on sonde les Français
sur l'impression qu'ils ont à l'issue du
débat pour chacun des candidats est-ce
que à l'issu débat vous en avez
uneimpression plutôt positive plutôt
négative les trois qui tirent leur
épingle du lot c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
devant Emmanuel Macron et devant
Philippe Poutou alors les deux premiers
peut-être Mélenchon parce que il devit
déjà cas à l'issu du premier
débat devait gommer une radicalité se
présidentialiser et qu'il y a réussi
peut-être qu'Emmanuel Macron devait
rassurer donner des dégage de sa stature
de de président Philip Poutou c'est
peut-être son audace qui qui l'a fait
émerger en tout cas on a vraiment ces
trois personnalités là qui ressortent
devant les autres après est-ce que ça va
faire bouger les lignes sur le plan
électoral c'est toujours une question
parce que qui regarde les débats est-ce
que ce sont les gens qui sont déjà
convaincu est-ce que parce que on sait
qu'il y a 38 % aujourd'hui des électeurs
qui voteront certainement qui n'ont pas
arrêté de choix mais est-ce que c'est
ces gens-là qui étaient derrière leur
poste ou peut-être avec vous ça vient ça
vient confirmer la la la bonne dynamique
he de Jean-Luc Mélenchon certainement ce
débat aussi sur jean-lque Mélanchon oui
effectivement c'est c'est une dynamique
qui qui s'imprène qui s'enracine
notamment paradoxalement depuis
l'élection à la primaire de de Benoît
amamont hein qui qui a émergé vous vous
souvenez qu'à ce moment-là fin janvier
il y a eu une inflexion hein de la côte
de popularité des intentions de vote de
de Jean-Luc de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
vous vous souvenez probablement que
Benoît amont comme on dit a raté le
début de sa campagne pendant un mois il
a fait ce surtout ce qu'on lui ne
demandait pas de faire c'est-à-dire les
les les les petits arrangements de
d'appareil politiqu on a vu qu'il avait
tenté de tendre la main au parti
communiste à Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il a
refusé de faire tous les pas les petits
pas et
finalement l'accord avec avec les vers
donc tout ça à à Benoît amont en aâti et
depuis ce moment-là la côte de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour différentes raisons qu'on
peut peut-être décliner bon une
personnalité qui a du pan on a on l'a
beaucoup dit hein une sorte de de de
fonction tribunicienne des beau disc des
beaux discours des citations en veutur
en voilà qui l'aide qui le pousse et
puis aussi à mon avis ce qui est très
important pour expliquer euh le le la
pente ascendante de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que lui-même a changé ce
n'est plus du tout le le
révolutionnaire rouge si je puis dire le
qu'il voulait incarnet il y a encore 5
ans ou même il y a encore quelques mois
il a mis beaucoup d'eau dans son vin
lui-même dit qu'il veut être et qu'il
apparaît et qu'il veul être cette figure
rassurante voir ce président potentiel
apaisant rassurant il a carrément
abandonner le concept de lutte des
classes pour ouvrir sur une vision de la
société plus diverse en intégrant
beaucoup l'écologie dans son programme
tout ça fait que pour le moment bah il a
damé le pion ça c'est pratiquement sûr
après on peut rien on peut pas injurier
laavenir il a damé le pion au PS à
Benoît amont et qui se retrouve côte à
côte avec avec François Fillon et et
peut-être Macron dans un dans un temps
avec enir phipe m vous êtes d'accord
c'est jean-lque Mélenchon qui sort une
nouvelle fois gagnant de ce débat on le
sait très à l'aise avec son rôle de TR
dire que c'est Mélenchon et le Pen pour
moi parce que les deux en fait ce type
de débat les aide à se dédiaboliser
parce qu'il y a plus extrêmes plus
fantasqu plus redoutable que finalement
donc ça les recentre et quelque part ce
qui est de frappant c'est que dans un
sondage récent Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
qualifié comme le plus rassurant des
hommes politique finalement ce qui est
quand même très étonnant quand on sait
d'où il vient donc oui c'est une bonne
opération ce débat moi j'ai trouvé que
Marine Le Pen c'est très à l'aise aussi
au fond c'est un petit peu inquiétant
parce que les deux candidats qui
viennent des positions les plus extrêmes
sont ceux qui dominent nettement
physiquement presque ces débats là alors
qu'on voit des candidats plus modérés
comme Macron comme Fillon être très
éteint presque en retrait et on se
demande quel impact de long terme ça
peut avoir sur l'électorat mais c'est
une vraie interrogation sur ces nouveaux
formats télévisés qui sont imposés par
les gens qui veulent les voir on a des
gens qui sont des des candidats modérés
qui ont qui ne sont pas à l'aise donc il
va falloir inventer une nouvelle façon
pour eux en tout cas de FA on verra avec
le débat du du second tour certainement
Thierry Vedel est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord est-ce que Marine Le Pen était
à l'aise certains disent qu'elle était
plutôt gênée justement et attaqué elle a
été très mauvaise sur les affaires les
affaires elle a été
exactement la difficulté toujours c'est
de faire la part entre les évaluations
d'experts ou même des téléspectateurs la
façon dont on regarde et dont on perçoit
le débat et puis ensuite les les les
effets que ça va avoir sur les
intentions de vote qui à mon avis sont
très très faibles hein je pense que
Marine Le Pen va rester à peu près dans
les mêmes niveau d'intention de vote et
Mélenchon même s'il est considéré par
beaucoup comme un très bon orateur
quelqu'un de très performant lors des
débats il va pas dépasser les 20 % non
plus où c'est très très peu probable
même s'il est très efficace lors d'un
débat il y a une enquête qui a été
réalisée par ELAB qui est très
intéressante aussi parce qu'elle
finalement elle révèle une certaine
contradiction de la part des citoyens en
général on veut la voir à la fois des
gens qui nous ressemblent qui sont comme
nous et en même temps qui ont la stature
présidentielle alors on aime bien Poutou
parce qu'il parle comme nous et il y
avait une question question de du
sondage etal c'était est-ce que il y a
des gens qui pensent comme vous et et
putou faisait un très bon score je crois
plus de 12 % et en revanche est-ce qu'il
a la stature présidentielle non donc à
la fois on voit les deux en même temps
on veut des gens qui soient proches de
nous qui nous ressemblent à la fois qui
qui est la stenture présidentielle et
qui soit différent de nous eran le sent
effectivement sur les modifications dans
les intentions de vote si on reprend le
triot tête que vous évoqué à l'instant
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Emmanuel Macron et
Philippe Poutou ça peut faire gagner
quelques point Philippe Poutou mais
peut-être pas forcément aux deux
premiers alors pour Emmanuel Macron on
peut faire l'hypothèse que ça ne devrait
pas changer énormément de choses à la
mesure où ça sa base de soutien dans les
intentions de vote n'attendez pas
forcément grand-chose de ce débat il a
des des soutiens dans l'opinion qui sont
plutôt des gens qui s'intéressent à
l'actualité qui s'intéressent à la
politique qui sont bien intégrés dans la
vie économique et sociale donc peut-être
qu'ils avaient moins d'attente à l'égard
de ce débat pour François Fillon c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué c'était un
débat où normalement il aurait pu
retaper sur Emmanuel Hollande réindiquer
qu'il était le candidat de l'alternance
que l'alternance elle se ferait avec
François Fillon et avec personne d'autre
et de montrer aussi qu'il avait une
stature d'homme d'État c'est le seul qui
a une expérience de 5 ans de l'exécutif
donc c'est tous ces élémentsl qu'il a
peut-être pas réussi à imprimer et qui
rendront peut-être un peu difficileant
qu'il avait sur sa route Nicolas
duponignan aussi on voyait clairement le
match entre François F du pignant en
parlant de beou en disant qu'il avait
travaillé pour Baou ce qui pour
l'électorat droite est horrible puisque
Baayou est un traîre en revanche c'est
vrai que Fillon était très éteint
pendant le débat et il a pas il a pas
vraiment attaqué quoi là pour rebondir
sur votre première question votre
seconde deuxè question sur l'utilité
d'un tel débat il y a quand même
puisqu'on parle des petits candidats
notamment du pontignan ou peut-être même
les deux d'extrême gauche Poutou et et
Madame harto ils peuvent avoir ils
peuvent avoir grapillé quelques
pourcentag voir quelques décimales et du
coup nuire doubl
carrément je dis pas ça mais si si si
c'est possibleoui doublé le pardon je
croyais doublé les grands candidats
quand on parle05 forcment doubl
mathématiquement par 0,5 en terme
d'automobile d'accord d'accord et donc
et donc je je je je termine les
candidats comme dupontignan peuvent
avoir fait un peu de mal soit on sait
pas d'ailleurs he soit à à Madame Le Pen
soit à Monsieur Fillon les deux
d'extrême gauche ont pu faire un peu de
mal à Monsieur Mélenchon par exemple et
donc et ben
empêcher entraver la dynamique de
Mélenchon ou de Le Pen et puis continuer
à à freiner le ou ajouter aux
difficultés de de Fillon à passer C
mélch c'est mélchon c'est moins sûr y a
une mutation de Mélanchon qui est
intéressante il est en train de prendre
de faire une opéa sur le PS sur la
position du PS en électorat même sur son
discours qui est complètement
hallucinante c'est il arrive à occuper
le de terrain de la gauche modérée c'est
pour ça qu'il veut être apaisant
rassurant il est apaisant il est fait
tout pour être apaisant et rassurant
mais si réuss historiquement d'abord
c'est une claque absolue pour la la
gauche du gouvernement et ensuite ça
veut dire qu'il peut dominer ce camp là
ce qui est intéressant bien sûr la
gauche du gouvernement et pour le Parti
socialiste même même sur son côté de
gauche enfin surés parti socialiste
c'est inquiétant pour lui ou quel impact
sur Emmanuel Macron on le sait
maintenant favori dans ce scrutin et on
se disait qu'il allait être la cible de
toutes les attaques finalement il a été
un peu épargné par ces adversaires hier
bah oui c'est c'est c'est un petit peu
une bonne stratégie électorale
d'attaquer celui qui apparis apparaît le
comme le favori hein euh alors ensuite
je crois qu'il y a quelque chose de très
important qui va progressivement jouer
que on n'a pas vu tellement apparaître
dans le débat un tout petit peu c'est
quand même que l'élection présidentielle
je l'ai déjà dit ici c'est pas
l'élection structurante forcément cette
fois-ci ça va être les élections
législatives et on commence à avoir ce
débat poindre un petit peu parce que je
je crois qu'il va devenir central et
notamment pour Mélenchon hein pour
Mélenchon est-ce qu'il pourrait avoir
une majorité de gouvernement et pour
Emmanuel Macron également et Marine Le
également un pe tout le monde pour pour
tout le monde tout à fait saufillon qui
mais qui aussi ramène le D ce thème là
parce que lui à priori c'est il est
celui qui peut disposer d'une majorité
parlementaire ou est-ce que ce débat va
conforter selon vous herwan nran la
position de favoris même s'il la récuse
cette position Emmanuel Macron mais le
le la position de favori d'Emmanuel
Macron elle est moins dans son score
d'intention de vote aujourd'hui que dans
le fait que François Fillon ne puisse
pas le rejoindre je pense que c'est
c'est là où se situe le le vrai match
électoral entre ces deux personnalités
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est que
François Fillon reste sous la barre des
20 % avec une stratégie qui est pas la
même que Jean-Luc Mélenchon jeanluc
Mélenchon finalement on voit que l'offre
de gauche les les électeurs de gauche se
sont repolarisés vers sa candidature
mais le total amont Mélenchon reste un
peu près le même donc j méenchan doit
trouver de nouveaux électeurs François
Fillon lui doit faire revenir des
électeurs qui sont partis dans un
contexte de radicalité de sa ligne
est-ce que ça le dessert le débat d'hier
il a été vraiment au centre de toutes
les attaques on l'a vu n pas émergé sur
le programme en tout cas mais c'est vrai
que on peut imaginer que son son rebond
ça ce électoral se fera parce que les
électeurs de la droite et du centre font
primer leur volonté d'alternance sur
leurs conviction à l'égard de des
affaires de François
Fillon ouais sur François Fillon euh je
je crois qu'il y a une une dichotomie
entre les appareils voir les élus qui
restent en tout cas pour 18 19 peut-être
20 % extrêmement fidèle à François
Fillon euh mais que les les électeurs
potentiels sur le terrain sont
terriblement choqués et eux soit ils
hésitent encore soit ils ont déjà
ralliés pour certains Marine Le Pen et
pour une part plus importante euh
Emmanuel Macron donc là je crois pour au
sein des républicains il y a vraiment
deux deux partis quoi il y a la tête et
le il y a la tête et les jambes si je
ces électeurs qui essayent de
d'accrocher Nicolas dupignon d'ailleurs
oui il essayie mais alors le problème
c'est que les électeurs de Fillon ceux
qui ont voté en tout cas la primaire
sont pas nécessairement ni antieuropéens
d'ailleurs c'est l'inverse ni forcément
souverainiste donc je sais pas dans
quelle mesure il va vraiment endre
là-dessus mais ce qui estinttéressant
quand même c'est que si ça arrive de
cette façon-là on va avoir une
disparition des deux partis enfin une
entame sur les deux parties de
gouvernement moi j'ai j'ai du mal à
croire ce Big Bang électoral mais s'il
arrive on sera dans un autre problème on
sera pas forcément dans une solution
politique c'est il y a beaucoup de gens
très enthousiaste à l'idée de ça c'est
qu'on change de paradigme et qu'on passe
à un paradigme on quitte le gauche-
droite et on va vers mondialisation
protection mondialisation Macron
protection Le Pen moi à titre personnel
ma réserve c'est de dire qui peut gagner
ce matchl est-ce que c'est forcément
Macron je suis pas sûr voilà Thierry
Vedel je le disais en France 2 renonce à
organiser un second débat il n' aura eu
que cette confrontation qu'en
retenez-vous avant le premier tour oui
parce qu'on aura aussi le le débat
probablement de l'entre de tour je crois
que Philippe tout à l'heure faisait
référence à quelque chose de très
intéressant il faut penser à un
renouvellement des formats politiques à
la télévision je crois qu'on reste
scotché un petit peu à cette idée de
débat qui pose d'énormes problèmes sur
le plan formel on s'aperçoit aussi que
certains candidats se présent à
l'élection présidentielle uniquement
pour bénéficier de la tribune
télévisuelle et parce queà ce moment-là
ils ont plus de temps de parole donc il
faut repenser tout ça je crois puis
inventer peut-être de nouvelles formules
pour la la politique à la télévision par
que chacun son programme Cheminade a
proposé de construire des planétarium
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui croit aux
extraterrestres il est
extraordinairement cohérent mais c'est
vrai est-ce qu'il a sa place dans un
débat présidentiel c'est une vraie
question et bien merci merci phppe chevr
merci merci merci janalim d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi à 22h vous retrouvez Sonia mabrou
et ses invités bonne soirée à tous et à
demain
[Musique]
18h